so we got to do shows over here so we
can't keep talking I definitely didn't
expect to talk about cannibalism
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
conservatives are very good at talking
about truth we own the libs with facts
and logic we're generally very good at
that
conservatives are pretty good at talking
about goodness
the the Moral Majority the religious
right this is good this is bad
conservatives are very very bad at
talking about that third transcendental
Beauty
here to help us speak about it a little
more accurately and persuasively is
Jonathan pajot who is an artist an
iconographer a man who who eludes titles
Jonathan thank you so much for coming on
thanks for having me it's great to be
here
conservatives love to talk about true
and false boom own statistic fact
debunked
conservatives
used to at least and to some degree
still do like to talk about morality and
ethics and you should do this and you
shouldn't do that
in in my lifetime conservatives have
just really ignored that third
transcendental yeah Beauty
is it because beauty doesn't matter or
is it because conservatives are just
missing something
I think they're not only missing
something but I think they're also
missing the key to their project because
beauty is is that which in which draws
you into to truth and and goodness you
know it's it is that it is the the
possibility of the world let's say being
transparent to something Transcendent
and it's but we see that it's beauty
that draws Us in and so the fact that
conservatives have been focusing a lot
on economics on let's say family values
all this stuff and ignoring Beauty means
that the other side has captured the
world through
through using those means let's say
twisting them for sure but using the
means of Beauty has been uh has been the
loss of the conservatives for sure
because
if I'm trying to win someone over to my
side of a political debate I guess I can
make some logical reasoned argument but
that might elude a lot of people or it
might just turn people off or they might
just not be interested yeah if I make a
moral argument a lot of people these
days when we're living in a in a an age
of materialism and moral ignorance and
idiocy if you don't mind the bluntness
that's probably not going to work very
well either they'll they'll turn to The
Big Lebowski argument they'll say well
that's just like your opinion man who
cares what morality is
but if I show someone a picture of a
beautiful sunset if I show someone a
picture of the Sistine Chapel the Duomo
or a beautiful mountain range
it kind of bypasses the reason it kind
of cuts right to the heart of some it
the the power of beauty seems much more
widely accessible exactly but
it's also I think one of the issues
we've had in the let's say the last few
centuries is that there's been a
movement especially with the emphasis on
reason there's been a movement where
beauty or the appearances are always
seen as something which is tricking you
something which is lying let's say and
sometimes that's true and we see that a
lot in advertisement and you know the
modern media has a lot of that but
there's a manner also in which because
we believe
that what crew what the origin of of
Truth and goodness you know is that
which creates the world it's that which
makes the world therefore the world is
made in a way that reflects that and
that's Beauty that's that's that exactly
it's like that that moment that cuts
through everything you know where you're
shaking in your body you know it's not
just about up here it's like your whole
body participates when you walk into a
beautiful building especially you know
you feel overwhelmed with the sense of
awe right the hairs on your neck stand
up and you feel like you're small and
that there's this amazing you're in this
amazing presence these are real they're
not uh Illusions these are real feelings
and they're you can imagine like even
imagine in the Bible do you imagine you
know the Israelites coming up to the
mountain and the mountain trembling and
you know the glory of God appearing on
the mountain these are appearances these
are things that are that are
let's say seizing people and and I think
that we we struggle with that especially
especially in North America I would say
you know we do have a kind of cult of
ugliness and also a cult of the banal is
the best way to think about it we love
things that are but now we have the
strip malls we have you know the
electric wires we have these huge
highways and so we've lost our sense of
this
of pattern we've lost our sense of
proportion and uh and because of that I
think our souls are are impoverished for
that
I totally agree with your point I was at
a wedding in the south of France last
year and I'm walking through these
medieval towns and I I remember I was
even walking through Paris and my wife
said how come they get this how come
they get to have this and we don't get
to have these beautiful things so I
totally agree
but why why do we in particular have
this Cult of ugliness in North America
I think it I think it's because North
America is really the product of the
modern world it really is a modern
country and it is founded on economic
good on economic progress you know on
business this these are the values that
sustain us and so you know when we we
make these large these huge glass Towers
you know that show Power and and
economic success but they lack the a
connection to the Transcendent that the
older buildings had so I I really think
that's what it is you know we we're very
practical we make the best computers we
make the best stuff but that's that also
has a corollary and there's also another
aspect which is that American North
American society in general has moved
away from Community as being let's say
the thing that binds us together and so
because of that urban planning has
suffered tremendously you know we've
basically planned our cities on based on
cars and so that totally transforms the
space traditional towns are hierarchical
in there the way that they're structured
so usually you'll have something like a
church in the center it's the highest
building the tower no nothing is allowed
to be higher than the church and
everything is aligned towards that
church so there's a sense in which the
entire
space even the the streets the manner in
which you you walk through has a human
scale to it and has an orientation and
you think well why does that make it
beautiful but it's it's about
orientation if you Orient yourself
properly then things will lay themselves
out almost naturally the beauty of a
medieval village isn't planned it is
this this negotiation it's like organic
negotiation of humans you know oriented
towards the same thing
our modern suburbs are monsters like
they're just these layouts of you know
houses and houses and houses with no
Center no common project nothing to bind
us together and so we create it's
because of the car like we create these
huge shopping districts and then living
districts and nobody even knows like
where you know we don't have places to
come together except for maybe
entertainment sporting events everything
so it's a it's a very deep deep problem
and it actually does start with
architecture and urban planning and then
everything kind of flows out of that
where we're we're used to living in
these inhuman
spaces and so because of it we we don't
see beauty as a value that that draws us
together
here's where conservative modern
conservatives will push back too yeah
because you're right I was thinking I
was walking around this town le beau in
Provence and at the very tippy top of
the town there is the old church and
it's a beautiful church and the whole
rest of the town is kind of descending
around that
but a modern American conservative might
say well well I don't give a damn about
that church who are you to tell me that
I can't build a building bigger than
that church I'm going to build a
skyscraper that's 10 zillion feet high
and I'm going to fill it up with a bunch
of bankers and I'm going to fill it up
with a bunch of lawyers and a bunch of
businesses and we're going to just make
money money and how and frankly forget
the office building for a second if I
want to build my house 10 000 feet high
I'm going to do that too and you have no
right to tell me otherwise
well in the end that might be true and
that might be fine in the sense that
okay yeah but then don't complain down
the line when you see things falling
apart and so don't complain down the
line when you realize that everybody is
doing their own thing in terms of
morality everybody's doing their own
things in terms of of how they conceive
of family how they conceive of of what
is good you know all these things come
together there's a reason why Plato has
the three transcendentals it's because
they actually are you could say
something like they're actually
transparent manifestations of something
infinite but you really need all three
or else or else you can't have the other
ones or you can fight for the other ones
but they're slowly going to disintegrate
it's difficult to hold that together but
by the way in the United States there
are counter movements and there are
count there are groups that are trying
to think of the world differently and so
there are some cities for example
Charleston South Carolina where there
are many groups of developers and groups
of Architects that are working to
recreate human size cities so there's a
neighborhood in near Charleston called
ion where the developer built the the
whole neighborhood and the first thing
he said is we need a church
uh at least two so they've got two
churches and and then they they made
everything human scale like the streets
are narrow so you have to wait for the
other cars to kind of go and I'm hearing
some conservatives like go like rip
their hair out but there's something
about let's say even how do you deal
with the problem of cars if you have to
slow down and you have to see the person
in front of you and negotiate a little
bit all the time then you're the car
doesn't become this like weird bubble
that you're just alone in it becomes a
space of relationship with others and
that's really what we so that's a way in
which Beauty can create Community it's
it's or making something more human
scale and beautiful is actually
encouraging Community now I can't help
but notice the conversation keeps coming
back to religion we didn't start it out
with religion we were just talking about
beauty but it keeps coming back to the
position of the church the way things
ought to be
we're living in a culture where religion
is collapsing where people the churches
are emptying where the largest spike in
religiosity is among the nuns and I'm
not talking about Catholic sisters in a
habit I'm talking about n-o-n-e-s people
who say they have no religion whatsoever
how are we supposed to restore a sense
of beauty if you seem to think that
religion is so Central to it
I think it I mean I'm not how can I say
this I'm afraid to say that I don't have
a lot of Hope for the big picture at
least for now I do have hope
for something like a seed which is being
planted so the reality is that truth
always wins sometimes it takes a while
sometimes it's painful and so I think
that for now what we need to do is
rather work locally you know and try to
plant seeds of the transcendentals of of
beautiful things you know work on our
families even our homes like to just
have a sense in which our homes are
little sacred spaces you know they they
have to be taken seriously we can't just
treat them as something to be used let's
say but they are the place where we
congregate you know even in terms of
setting the table for example that's a
little example but it's like in our
house we set the table every day for
dinner and it's a little ritual but it's
something which reminds us that you know
we're sitting together we have to care
for the place in which we're sitting we
have to treat it as if it's valuable and
these are little moments of beauty that
can help work people up towards you know
understanding the importance of of space
the importance of proportion in in our
human interactions even I think it was
Christopher Alexander who said that
every space that you are in will either
slightly Elevate or slightly lower your
spirits and so the home is so important
here and this was
the only time that my wife and I really
bicker
is is over ordering furniture and it's
not because we have different tastes in
Furniture we don't but it's because I
drag out this process and sometimes
sweet little Elisa my wife she just she
says we just got to order a crib we just
got to get a lamp we've just got it come
on just go and I say no because I'm
going to have to look at that crib or
that lamp or that and it's go I'm gonna
have to look at it all the time and I
need it to be beautiful and I need it to
elevate the space and and by the way in
her defense it's very hard even to
purchase beautiful things even for the
home now and I'm not saying they've got
to be super fancy or expensive there are
plenty of beautiful things that are very
very inexpensive some of which are even
free you can you can get them from
nature and manipulate them but it's very
difficult to find them because
everything is mass produced in some
Factory in China following one of the
stupidest maxims that has ever come to
dominate a civilization which is form
follows function yeah definitely I
totally we have this same issue at our
house as well but we agree though we
don't we're no bigger but we have at
some point I think about maybe six years
ago we decided that whatever we get for
the house we are going to get the best
thing for that place for that moment and
it yeah sometimes the that space remains
empty for sadly sometimes a year
but it's like no we're gonna get it
right especially my wife like she's
really uh and and when it happens then
it's like it is like this almost it's
like family member that enters into the
house because we're careful we took time
to really decide uh one of the problems
we have too which is actually a big
I would say an enemy of beauty is
fashion this is a big problem because
people mistake the wow of the new and
the surprise of something unusual or
something surprising they they really
tend to confuse that with beauty they're
not the same and and it's difficult
because we really have to retrain
ourselves to think outside of fashion
it's not that it's not that things don't
change forever things have always
changed you know Styles slowly change
with time and there's there there's
there's that flow but we live in a world
where things are so intense where we buy
something and then two years later it's
almost embarrassing to have that thing
in the house and so I would I would
people need to retrain themselves to
learn to see through the Fashions and
recognize that the more stable patterns
that will will be able to create Beauty
in your house without creating
you will miss that like when people walk
in and go wow look at that thing you got
because you know it's so impressive and
so exciting for the moment you'll miss
that but you'll get a better sense of of
being in a space that you can inhabit
and that that is gonna how can I say
this it's gonna grow old with you you
can live in that space you know a piece
of furniture that has been lived with
for years you know almost becomes a part
of your family like a part of your world
and it has a life in your family so
thinking of it that way can I think help
people to uh to see through either the
ugly practical plastic fork you know
aspect of our world but also this kind
of high glitzy fashion world we live in
this Insanity of extremes is what that's
the problem and there there is an infant
and financial motivation here as well
which is that
if if you deck out your home in the
green shag carpet and you fill your
closet with powder blue suits you're
you're going to need to change that
fashion uh within six months well really
you should change it immediately but
certainly within six months or a couple
of years whereas if you have something
that is more traditional it's not that
you're just going back to something
that's old and stodgy and outdated
that's not what tradition is tradition
is the opposite tradition is that which
has endured it's in many ways it's the
most vibrant vivacious new thing in the
world and
you know I guess I guess this brings us
back a little bit to Christianity right
we keep sort of circling around
described as the uh religion that is
ever ancient ever knew
you are not just an artist you are an
iconographer not just an iconographer a
Christian iconographer is that just a
coincidence not at all you know I
studied Fine Art when I was in my 20s
and I I struggled a lot to find a way to
integrate myself let's say first of all
as a Christian I was doing Contemporary
Art which is already a problem because
it's so cynical and so you know and so
heady and and it's difficult to make
something you're always making a comment
on something and I really wanted to
create things that had a place in the
world
um so already that was a problem but and
then also I needed to find a language
and discovering the traditional call it
the traditional language of the church
uh you know the church developed this
powerful visual language for like the
first 1000 years and it wasn't top down
it was this really organic negotiation
if you went in a church like in Spain or
if you went to Syria or to England you
would have recognized what you see there
was like this universal language I would
say and so diving back into that
universal language to me is very
deliberate because I think that
our understanding of Art and our
participation and culture if we want to
renew it even at the level of
entertainment or at the level of of a
you know of a Furniture it has to start
in the highest place and so for me this
was really a strategy so I make I make
images for churches I make
things chalices things that people use
within within the traditional churches
but I also make t-shirts and I wrote a
graphic novel and and I write fairy
tales and so for me all of this is
connected together that is
none of nothing is bad like t-shirts are
fine it's okay to wear a t-shirt but
don't wear a t-shirt when you you go to
church let's say right it's like just
just everything has to be in its place
and I think four things to kind of flow
down and Orient themselves properly they
have to start in the highest and so for
me it was really important to ReDiscover
the Christian Aesthetics and the
Christian language of Art in order to
then
know that later I would be making other
things and and having them let's say
flow down from that and I think it's the
same with architecture for example like
if we recapture beautiful churches
that's probably the best thing we can do
and then the world will flow slowly out
of that it's going to take time but
we're going to at least have the place
where we gather together and we
recognize what is highest
that's what we're doing we're in church
we're like this is what is highest so if
the space is this ugly
thing that looks like a strip mall right
you know we're not we're honoring even
if it's not overtly ugly even if it's
not aggressively ugly even if it's just
plain and ordinary but now no I totally
agree I always tell people you know your
your church should really be nicer than
your house that you just keep that if
you at least keep that hierarchy and
make sure that your church is nicer than
your house then you should be okay there
is though there is a traditional
language of of Christianity even in the
architecture as well that is the most I
think reflective of what of what a
church is and you see that like there's
still plenty of churches that have that
but it's difficult a lot of the modern
churches they either going for the
entertainment mode you know they're
going for a theater you know or uh
something that's more like a stadium uh
and that it's reflecting of it's
reflective of what you're doing you know
spaces aren't arbitrary spaces have
the way we give our attention to things
and the way that things happen have
meaning you can't avoid it no like let's
say this is going to be hostile to a lot
of people I understand but if you stand
in front of people
the way you dress is going to affect the
impression you give it doesn't matter
what what you want so if you're standing
in front of everybody and you're saying
well I'm gonna not I don't want my
clothing to say something so I'm going
to wear like ripped jeans and I'm going
to have messy hair I'm going to sit on
the side of the stage you're saying
something my friend inevitably you're
inevitably saying something by your
demeanor by the way you're dressed and
so I think that one of the powerful
thing of the traditional Christian
churches is that they were able to
create a language that every piece of
clothing that a priest wears in the
Catholic church or the Orthodox Church
is related to a Psalm like for sure in
the Orthodox Church when they they wear
they put their clothing on they say
prayers they actually recite Psalms as
they put on their clothing and so
they're putting themselves in a space
where they're going to really represent
what it is they want to represent which
is they want to gather the people you
know in attention to God and the space
is the same the tripartite way that a
traditional church is set up is is there
specifically for a reason the altar is
higher than the seeds I know you know if
you have a place where all the seats are
higher then the the stage let's say
you're saying something you know you're
you're you're and you you're you can't
avoid entering into the language of
hierarchy that's in scripture like going
up the mountain you know Jesus going up
the mountain or or Moses going up the
mountain you have to think about that
because that's the world in which we
have our experience so if you create a
stadium where you know all the viewers
are higher than the pass there
you're saying something and even if you
even if it's it's not explicit it's
going to imbibe the culture and it's
going to it's going to affect the way
you understand the world because we have
bodies that's right we're incarnate it's
just unavoidable we we perceive the
world the same reason your head is at
the top of your body you know for the
same reason these hierarchies of
attention are the same reason when you
lift your head up you know to look over
something or to to see the Sun or to you
know these are all real embodied
realities that we deal with well you
mention this big shift in the culture
and specifically in churches from
reverence and worship of God to more
entertainment and you see this
especially in the Catholic church in the
1960s really 1970 and afterward the the
mass was changed radically such that the
priest who since time immemorial had
faced The Altar and all the people in
the priest were facing the altar
together worshiping God the priest
turned around and faced the people and a
priest friend of mine father George
rutler in New York described what
happened then which is the pre priests
would begin to entertain they would they
would often tell jokes you said like a
like a ham actor in a dying Vaudeville
show they would tell jokes they they
might consider my my priest friend
suggested limiting their repertoire to
the jokes that Saint John told the
Blessed Mother while her son bled on the
cross you know previously
how's that imagery yeah there you go
previously
in and I know this because I attend the
traditional Latin Mass
and and that had been robbed we had been
robbed of that mass for most of my life
until in the 2000s Pope Benedict started
to loosen it up again and allow people
to go back to it it was a total
Revelation to me because I grew up in
the era of priests making dumb jokes and
the the hymns being lame little ditties
from the 70s that weren't even cool in
the 70s and acoustic guitars and felt
banners and just ugly banal Bland
whitewashed churches and and
iconoclastic kind of moment where you
take out all of the beauty and then I
began to glimpse a mass where all of
every syllable is a symbol every article
of the priest's clothing as you
mentioned all of the language all of the
chanting all of the orientation of
everything is symbolic of something it
has it's imbued with meaning and I said
oh my gosh we're really doing something
here this is really significant oh I
totally agree I mean I I'm an Orthodox
Christian and so
this is luckily we haven't had that
change let's say so we really we live in
that that world where the purpose of
church is to worship and it's not it's
something which is
it really does reflect North American
culture and I think sometimes you could
say that at least here it happened in
ways that are insipid people didn't
totally realize what was going on but
there's a man in which we View Church as
something that we consume this is yeah
just an inevitable part of our the way
we understand culture as also
entertainment that we've reduced culture
to entertainment and so that got gets
brought into the church where we're
there to consume whatever it is that is
going to be presented to us and that is
a problem it is a problem
um and it's it's definitely helpful to
have properly oriented spaces and
properly oriented
liturgies to help us understand that no
we need to orient ourselves towards God
everything and if we do that then the
world will it's funny
if we Orient ourselves towards God
properly then everything will kind of
flow even in terms of beauty that's what
I was saying before is that for me
becoming an iconographer it was about
orienting my art practice in the highest
way possible in a world also where it
was so weird to do that it's like okay
you're an iconographer you're I'm an
icon Carver who how many of those are
there in North America yeah I can count
them on two fingers really and so uh and
but still it was like it was a very
strange thing to do but I knew that I
had to in order for anything else that I
do to flow I it had to be oriented
properly it's the same with our family
so if we if we think of church as a
place to consume
that say songs and messages or whatever
then when we go home and we sit at the
table we think that food is just there
to consume and so we'll we'll watch our
family dinners erode you know in for
this Downstream from the manner in which
we worship and it's going to happen in
the culture generally right it's not
something it's not a direct correlation
but we'll see it kind of happen whereas
we don't Orient ourselves properly then
things are going to start to fragment
you'll come to a point where people
families don't even sit together at all
is a principle Lexa Randi Lex credenti
Lex vivendi the way that we worship
affects the way that we believe it
determines the way that we believe and
it determines the way that we live so
you're talking about this orientation
all coming to it affects the whole rest
of life I
I can't help but think that when God is
asked what his name is the Burning Bush
Moses asks God who are you he says I am
who I am I I am I am being himself right
I'm and when we find our identity in I
am who I am things make sense when we
reject I am who I am when we reject
being himself
we're left with this question which is
who am I and we've got this identity
crisis and right now specifically that
identity crisis is is manifesting in
gender as transgender moment where uh
more than one in five Zoomers are
identifying as LGBT and where you've got
a huge spike in even childhood
transvestitism and gender dysphoria Who
Am I who Am I who am I
can't help but notice that
symbol is at the very heart of that
question the the body is a symbol of our
soul for instance no you're absolutely
right it and it's something which the
way that you framed it is perfect
because it does have to do with the
problem of being and so you can think
about it fractively about anything like
it doesn't have to be just god let's say
you know
there is there is a wind which you
recognize the being of something so
let's say like a chair you have a way to
recognize it and you have multiplicity
like there's variation right there's
variation of chairs there's all kinds of
different chairs but the further you get
away let's say from what you recognize
as a chair you're going to start to see
things get weird where you're going to
start to see let's say well it doesn't
it's kind of like a chair kind of like a
stool it's kind of in between it's a
it's like a hybrid between a chair and a
bench and so you start to see exceptions
and and strangeness and those are in
some ways they're actually okay if we're
all oriented towards you know the the
being in the first place and so this is
what we're seeing happening everywhere
which is that we're moving into
exception hybridity so that's the
difference that's the opposite of being
is that if you move away from being you
move into confusion into things that
have different identities so if you
think about
so I like to help people understand
let's say you think about a traditional
Church yeah a traditional church is
built exactly like this like a gothic
church for example is a good way to say
it so we at the center we have the altar
it's the highest place it's the place
where the Heaven and Earth meet right
the priest lifts up the chalice and he
and he shows you like heaven and earth
is meeting right here this is the spot
where being is manifesting itself in its
fullness and then we we have the people
that are there and there's multiplicity
and there's all this stuff then in the
corners and in the edges and in on the
outside that's where we have gargoyles
and gargoyles are fine right in their
proper place and that's what they are
they're ambiguous they're they're
humorous they're confused they're a
strange mixture of different identities
they usually have a kind of uh
irreverent uh nature to them sometimes
they're even kind of uh even off-key
like a little salty let's say and they
have their place in the structure but
only if they're in their proper place if
you take a gargoyle and you put it on
the altar like you're in trouble
and I think that this is what's going on
is that exceptions will always exist so
there's a sense in which the argument of
the
of let's say the LGBT argument to say
that there's some fluidity it's it's
true but the fluidity is on the edges
it's always in the exceptions and on the
edges and in strangeness but you can't
make strangeness
the thing that you worship
because then everything falls apart so
if you if you if you have like a whole
month where you're celebrating
uh idiosyncrasy and strangeness and and
ambiguity
and it actually becomes the only thing
you're allowed to celebrate like if you
want to know where a culture is look at
what you're allowed to celebrate and so
as there's a war on let's say the Fourth
of July for you for Americans at War on
the idea of saying the holidays instead
of saying Christmas like all this kind
of little this little fight in language
and what it is that we are that we
should and are allowed to celebrate at
the same time that there's rising up of
entire swas of our liturgical year we
could say to worship ambiguity and
idiosyncrasy and strangeness
that's a sign it's related to being
itself it's related to the manner in
which being reaches its Edge and and and
yeah so and you're you're getting
contradictory
protestations coming out of the left
I've noticed specifically on this
question the left will try to change all
of our language and force us to call men
her and women he and they will they will
force us to say happy holidays instead
of Christmas what holiday are we talking
about folks you know there's one big
holiday here that we're all talking
about we're not allowed to say it
they'll say this is so important change
the language change the language change
language and also what do you
conservatives care about come on it's
just words it's just symbols who cares
uh you care you're the one who's making
me change all of the language so and
yeah and also I mean like the language
becomes in the idiotic syncretic
language is so precise like the whole
pronoun things you have to use this
pronoun you have to use this and and
then there's the you know and then
there's all these multiple terms like
exploding multiple terms to how to
define someone and if you don't use that
like you're actually making them not
exist like right you're refusing their
actual existence so no it I mean it
really is it was never about it doesn't
matter it really is about what matters I
mean
humans can't live without things that
are important in a hierarchy of values
and so it was never although people will
say oh we just have to flatten
everything we have to make everything
kind of like this that it's never true
that's always a lie it always ends up
with a kind of hierarchy of values and
in a way the way to
right now what we're seeing is something
like an upside down hierarchy is the
best way to understand it you know and
so it's like where the exception is the
rule you know we used to say the
exception proves the rule yeah it's like
there's exception and so you can see the
rule and so now no no now it's like the
exception not only the the exception
exception invalidate the rule it becomes
the new rule and everything is kind of
directly towards the exception they'll
say this with hermaphrodites they will
say well because there are like four
hermaphrodites in the entire world this
proves that men and women are not
discrete categories that really exist
and I think first of all
even hermaphrodites can be classified as
man or woman in virtually all cases but
ligers exist there's such a thing as a
liger yeah it is a it is a hybrid of a
lion and a tiger the existence of
probably a similar number of ligers that
there are hermaphrodites it does not
negate the existence of lions and tigers
yeah well it's because people can't
think in hierarchies anymore in a way
but they do secretly but they say
publicly they don't really think it in
hierarchies they they do think in these
weird radical opposites and so but it's
a trick like the post-modern trick has
been to take the everything ambiguous
everything that's kind of in the margin
and use it as a tool to devour It's Like
A Parasite like it's like a but and I
say that people will go like oh
Jonathan's saying it's a parasite no the
postmoderns are very much aware like has
a famous interview where he said that
every his whole work is about
parasitology it's about virology and
that it's about introducing a parasite
that slowly devours the host and the
exception devours the rule right the
thing that's writing the world is slowly
kind of deconstructing the the main the
main body let's say and this is so it's
it's not this is something that is
weaponized like it's it's deliberate
when we're talking about these
exceptions then I I have to wonder if
conservatives are
if we're taking the wrong tack here if
we're holding the wrong story I think
they are because you know there's
especially when it comes to gender yeah
we we deny gender expression we say
gender expression is this totally bogus
thing I've said this myself it's this
bogus thing it's ridiculous I mean
there's just sex there's boys and girls
XX and XY chromosomes and that's that
but it's an ancient it's actually a very
ancient uh way of thinking that gender
and sex are not exactly the same I mean
they're find it in like the Byzantine
Empire they had this notion that is they
weren't exactly the same well and and it
it only makes sense because
symbol symbols and the symbolized are
not exactly the same I am of the opinion
that symbols should
precisely and accurately reflect that
which is symbolized and the further a
symbol gets from what it is symbolizing
the more trouble you're going to have
but they are they are different things
you know if if a if gender expression is
the symbol that which is symbolized is
biological sex just as if my body is the
symbol my my soul is that which is being
symbolized the idea that the soul is the
form of the body and and actually it
keeps it keeps coming back to religion I
mean this has been a real point of
of great significance between the
Catholics and the Protestants and the
Orthodox too I suppose which is that in
the Eucharist you have the total Unity
of the symbol and the symbolize the
bread is the symbol Jesus Christ's body
and blood is the symbolized and the
Catholics and the Orthodox believe yeah
they are both together in some
Protestants believe that here they are
both together and after the Protestant
Revolution you see different Christian
groups move further and further away
from this and you say no it's merely a
symbol and you're rendering these two
things apart no I totally agree there's
definitely
something about the breakdown of
Eucharistic theology is I mean this is
going very far in the past but it's
definitely part of how why are their
vision of the world has broken down and
why these these weird separations like
radical separations between exactly that
between let's say the referent and that
which is reference has come together but
in terms of like in terms of like the
the this difficult situation with gender
and and desire that we're dealing with
now we have to understand that modernism
is a funny thing that modernism has is
Extreme it tends towards extremes so
what we're going through now for all
this the difficulty that it's bringing
is is a reaction to something that
happened at the beginning of the early
20th century which is that we
pathologized everything and so like men
were being castrated in the 1950s we
have to remember that and that a lot of
the things that are going on now are
like a reaction to that where we had a
black and white crazy black and white
world after World War II was like this
this this this everything was was was
was completely hermetic in black and
white the world doesn't work that way
there is fluidity does exist it only it
exists on the edges and if we try to
eliminate fluidity if we try to
eliminate exceptions and strangeness
then it'll come back with a vengeance so
in the Bible you have this image for
example of the field and you know the
Israelites were supposed to till their
field but leave the corners until you're
supposed to leave the corners on tilled
for the stranger and the poor and the
stranger so the sense in which the world
can't be completely
can't be completely filled you have to
leave a remainder on the edge and you
know the idea of having a fringe on your
investment for example is a good example
so it's like you have your the Hem of
the investment stops then you leave a
little bit of wild on the edge that's
something that has always existed in all
societies so I'm not trying to justify
morally this or that behavior but
there's a man in which traditional
societies would would always recognize
that exceptions happen and that we just
have to kind of deal with it privately
and in our you know in our not deal with
it publicly in a way that is related to
law but deal with it privately in the in
the world of exceptions and strangers
and in the places where our own symbols
don't totally fit with that which is
symbolized and now now the fringes are
at the center of society right people
who frequently I hate to be offensive
they frequently look like gargoyles are
at the center of society and I I also
can't help but notice that the people
who mutilate themselves in in these ways
and to
it's not merely that a man is dressing
up like Donna Reed okay it's usually a
man mutilating himself in ways that's
often seem to have very little to do
with sex or that are extraordinary
caricatures of what a woman is or very
frequently that involve occult symbolism
I mean overtly occult symbolism here and
if you if you put that sort of
ugliness if you make yourself uglier
than you otherwise would be and you put
that ugliness at the center of a society
I my question that I struggle with is
why don't we all just reject it out of
hand and say yuck between a a beautiful
artistic environment and this Cult of
ugliness give me the beauty yeah why are
we still being drawn into this
I think it's actually this is more
something like a sign of the times so
think about okay so a normal society
will always have some of that it's there
in every traditional Society so think
about Carnival so traditional societies
had a carnival and that Carnival would
be the place where all the idiosyncrasy
upside down Behavior strangeness a
little bit of lewdness a little bit of
that you know a little bit of
drunkenness it's like okay we kind of
turn the open the valve a little bit let
some of that out then we close it down
and we go back into normal world and so
this is something we see in the Jewish
tradition the apuram we have things like
Mardi Gras and we still have let's say
Halloween as an example of of that
moment where we kind of embody
monstrosity and strangeness and
exception so this is something that has
always been part of every single
traditional Society in the history of
the world now
think about as if like this was a really
really big version of that cycle and now
the whole world is just a giant Carnival
it's all Mardi Gras right it's all Mardi
Gras all the time right so I think that
that's the best way to understand it so
there is a manner in which
just like in a normal Mardi Gras we
would we would leave a little bit of
space for that and there's something
about understanding the reality of
idiosyncrasy which is necessary that's
why there are gargoyles that's why like
on the edge of manuscripts there'd be
like all these like funny figures doing
weird things because that is actually
part of reality if we deny it
we're we're like if we deny it we're
denying a part of reality and it's going
to the world is going to fix and
crystallize and it's going to shatter
and so that's it like that's where we
are we're basically in the massive
Carnival now the problem is that living
in a carnival is not for a very long
time is not good for your soul and
making Carnival your identity I mean
think of a Carne for example like have
it we have an image of the carnies and
there those images are not just cliches
like people who live in the carnival all
the time they tend to degenerate and
fall into their own passions and and you
know have very very dangerous Lifestyles
let's say and so it's like think about
it now a whole society that is
worshiping the Carney
this is this is that they're not it's
not a good it's not a good moment it's
not a good spot but the solution
I don't I honestly think that the
solution is not to just
bring the knife down and say chop the
solution is really to say we need to
find a way
to understand the inevitability of
strangeness and I find ways to integrate
it so having proper Mardi Gras like
having proper celebrations but then also
then saying okay well we're done now
let's move into normality
um so I think that's I think that
conservatives have to I know it's it's
difficult because conservatives have a
very large discussed mechanism like they
tend to get disgusted with which I
understand but
we can't just rely on that we need to we
need to if we want to find like a better
world we need to be able to
to understand the inevitability of
strangeness this is going to be part of
your world no matter what you can't get
away from it but but you have to put it
in its property that's right it has to
be in its proper place which is on The
Fringe on the that's what all the
language it's already that like The
Fringe the margin the exception like the
the the water on the edge of the world
right the fluidity that exists on the
edge of reality why is everybody getting
tattoos
idiosyncrasy
it has to do with the fact of let's say
emphasizing idiosyncrasy to a level that
is so completely insane you know and
that it's no longer that it's all
exactly it becomes like a strange new
rule there's there's something about
that but there's also something about
one of the things we're seeing and this
is difficult is that we're kind of
seeing religion pour back into the world
and this is happening in very strange
ways that anybody who's who followed the
George Floyd protest would have noticed
to what extent those were religious and
tone the you know the processions the
people flocking themselves like kneeling
and doing all these things and so
there's a way in which people are hungry
for the sacred they're hungry for sacred
things well they literally made icons of
George Floyd that you can see in cities
around the country and they they even
framed it as a human sacrifice like a
few people of politicians and so this is
happening like this is inevitable now
the problem is that
we are making the idiosyncratic sacred
uh and so I think that people who get
tattoos they really
see it or they experience it as
something of a sacred thing like they're
it's like they're marking themselves
right in the part of their identity yeah
they're they're adjusting their identity
they're marking their bodies in ways to
to like I know like a circumcision but
like idiosyncratic circumcision right
something like that uh and so it I think
it's also part of the Sacred kind of
flooding back in to the world I was in
at the Apple Store in Grand Central
years ago and I had to buy a computer
charger and I was talking to the guy
who's the salesman and I noticed he's
got two tattoos I'm sure he had many
more tattoos but he had two on his
fingers on the index finger he had a
little tiny mustache and on the side of
the ring finger it said in a beautiful
little cursive [ __ ] cray
and I thought you know
that's very descriptive that's that's
precise yeah it is cray yeah you're
you're and and I I racked I'm thinking
about it to this day this was probably
10 years ago I bought this computer
charger
why you would brand yourself that with a
symbol essentially of meaninglessness
nobody's lying that's the thing it's
like people feels the meaningless people
tell you what they're up to if you if
you know how to pay attention you know
and so so I think that that a lot of
things that are happening today are just
basic people just saying what they're
doing it's not uh and so that's it like
you could say it's like a fetishization
of of idiosyncrasy in a way that is
almost like a making sacred of the of
stupidity and banality and and uh
absurdity yeah absurdity and also like
the thing of the thing about this is
getting a little deep I didn't think
we'd go this deep but so there's a sense
in which this is tension which there are
two taboos right and you see that in the
Bible you see that in every culture
there's a sacred taboo yeah right and so
the sacred taboo is something like
something which is too high I don't have
access to it's hidden behind veils it's
hidden behind Sublimity exactly but
there's another taboo which is all the
things that you
say push away from yourself so
everything all the fecal stuff all the
like the the things that are meant to be
in private that are meant to be hidden
like like nakedness uh you know uh and
and also like
if you had some kind of deformity or
whatever like you would tend to want to
to not put that out there like to kind
of hide it or whatever and so those two
taboos
so there's a there's a way in which EX
in an extremely high high manner
Christ transcends that and brings them
together in ways that are is crazy so
Christ on the cross naked on the cross
beaten you know with the with the sign
saying that he's the king you know with
a crown of thorns he joins it all
together like it's it's wild but in the
normal World those are separate right
and you want to keep them separate but
there's a little trick that people can
play is to to to confuse one for the
other and that's a lot of what we're
seeing there's a sense in which
revealing the taboo of that which is
dirty and disgusting and and uh the
things that you're usually hide and cut
off gives them a little sense of
Sublimity it makes them feel like
they're participating in something
sacred so it's like it really is like a
kind of satanic that's why that's why
the occult is part of this it is like a
weird kind of satanic secret which if I
if I expose the dark taboos then I can
trick people in thinking it's the same
as the as the secret there's the Divine
Secret let's say that's a beautiful
point
the the conservatives over the last 10
or so years have driven me crazy because
they've they've they drive me crazy all
the time but but because I love them and
I don't want to see them do the wrong
thing they've adopted this position of
free speech absolutism and they'll say
we should we should be able to say
whatever we want whenever we want to say
it at all times that's a good free
flourishing Society
I say have you ever read a history book
or thought about human nature or even
just looked around with your own two
eyes every society has taboos Society
necessarily has not just standards but
overt taboos things that cannot be
uttered things that will be held either
sacred or so incredibly profane that we
in vulgar that we just keep it away
and the so conservatives just completely
missed the boat of what's going on as so
often they do and your observation that
the left
their little trick is that's right
they'll flip those things oh yeah and
that's what I like that's why people are
talking about cannibalism right now this
is not arbitrary these are these are
real
let's say moments where
the world is being is being invaded by
meaningful things and so the fact that
the the weird kind of leftist people are
are obsessed with like bringing up
cannibalism constantly they just keep
doing it or just the idea of eating bugs
for example like all of this type of
thing where we want to take the
strangeness and the weirdness and we
want to elevate it up to the top it's
like these all have coherence like these
are the nothing of this is accidental it
doesn't mean that it's like a conspiracy
that people are controlling it's like
these patterns play themselves out we
fall under principalities and and we
play things out even without knowing
what we're doing but the idea of
cannibalism for example is a good
example like we have
the Eucharist that is the highest it is
taboo it is hidden it is secret it is
and then you have vulgar like breakdown
of causality where you gonna eat not
only cannibalism but you know you know
how they wrote these these articles
about like growing your own meat of your
own body and eating it's like do you
understand that you're at the end of the
world when you do that like when you
have self-causing like self uh like you
have a breakdown of causality where it's
just circularity it's like the serpent
eating its tail it's like you really
want to engage in that you're bringing
about the end of the world people like
this is not good yeah but it's so
titillating that's right exactly it has
that kind of taboo titillation to it
because I I think you see this
especially in in porn this this is a
major cultural shift that over the last
what 10 or 15 years
porn is everywhere and it's because of
the internet and because of cell phones
and laptops people just have access to
anything they could possibly imagine or
not even imagine they've got that at
their fingertips for free blazing fast
people write into my show constantly and
as a young man who say I got hooked on
porn my life has been destroyed by porn
I'm addicted it's perverted not even
just my relationships but the whole way
that I view the world yeah I read some
study it's like 92 percent of
men have looked at porn a lot in their
life presumably eight percent are liars
you know that's the caveat to the study
yeah and and you know especially in
pornography since time immemorial you
see a lot of this overt occult kind of
imagery
it would seem to me that the way to
understand porn is that porn is an act
of worship yeah is this it's definitely
sacred like there's something sacred
well sexuality is sacred but there's a
mat you could understand that
Christian sexuality is sacred and
sublimated like it moves towards
sublimation so it's not completely
sublimated but it moved towards like
let's say ultimately you're you're the
highest point of sexuality is to be the
bride of Christ like that it would be
like the highest point of the church is
the bride of Christ you think of Dante
uh
his erotic love for Beatrice his lover
leads him directly to this vision of God
exactly so that's a that's a beautiful
image of that but now so porn is a is is
a
so if you want to understand in the
Middle Ages when they talked about like
incuba and succubi like you can
understand that pretty well right now
like we this is what's going on we're
being invaded by by succubi and incubi
and these and the the porn is a medium
by which sexuality is being our
attention and our sexual attention is
being pulled as far away as possible
from the sublimation of it but what it
means is that it's also being pulled
away from the lower levels which we
which means just having normal sexual
relationships with your spouse you know
having children all this and so it's
like it's pulling us away into a kind of
worship that is people are gonna maybe
not I hope they understand but it is in
a way a kind of demon worship of course
it is because because the obviously the
people you're not engaging with the
people that you see in the porn like
they're just disembodied images Spirit
yeah they're vehicles for this this like
breakdown of sexuality into all these
idiosyncrasies so it's a it's a perfect
example like if you if you want to
understand when the in the Middle Ages
when they talk about these demons like
ah we got them now like this is actually
what's going on uh and so and the
purpose if you read in the Middle Ages
if you read like the books that talk
about these things they were saying that
the purpose is to undo the world like
that's the purpose is to the purpose of
the incubus and the succubus is to take
the male seed you know and to let's say
have also it's a have women not have
normal relationships with their husband
so that the world will be undone
basically and this is I mean we're
seeing it happen for our very eyes like
it's you know the birth rates are
falling like crazy people like young
young healthy people like they're just
not having entering into normal
relationships with people from the
opposite sex and it's just ripping us
all apart and it's part of and it's just
weird it's so weird because it's so
clear now it's actually a good time to
be alive in some ways because you know
30 years ago 20 years ago she had said
oh this is anti-human like people
actually want humans to exist as little
as possible who said oh come on Jonathan
you're making it up it's like well at
this point it's pretty clear because now
they're just saying it straight out like
we just want humans to exist as little
as possible and to remove them to like
remove them from the earth as much as we
can and it's like it's an actual agenda
that is up there in the you know in the
official agendas of the U.N or whatever
right big organization well you see the
two images of sexuality in our culture
you've got the one you've just described
of sublimating or sexuality to be the
bride of Christ you know Dante looking
up at Beatrice leads them right up to
God and then the other one is 50 Shades
of Gray that's right and I I can't help
but notice the the former the the Dante
in the Beatrice and the bride of Christ
it's full of angels and harps and bright
light and beauty and then the 50 Shades
of Gray is full of you're just whipping
people and chains it looks like hell no
one's pretending anymore like look at an
image of hell like from the Middle Ages
the one that your professors made fun of
Christians for believing and then that's
the world that's it these are the images
that entice people today and so what are
you gonna do it's like this this
nobody's lying anymore nobody's lying I
love that line nobody's lying you can't
escape it you can't escape meaning you
can't escape symbolism like that old
political philosopher Bob Dylan pointed
out that moral Theologian everybody's
got to serve somebody yes and you you
there is no neutrality here you're going
one way or the other
Jonathan I could stay here all day but
my producers won't let me thank you so
much for coming up that's great thanks
for the opportunity wonderful
[Music]
[Music]